something astonishing happens in Ireland
in the waning years of the 19th century
and the early years of the 20th in this
small island on the edge of Europe a
remarkable cluster of writers emerged at
nearly the same time and the same place
these writers ranked among the greatest
in Western history William Butler Yeats
George Bernard Shaw James Joyce John
Millington Synge and many others what is
even more striking they emerged at the
very moment in history when Ireland
finally attained its long-awaited
independence from Great Britain after
suffering English occupation in one form
or another for seven long centuries
Ireland rested its independence from
England in the same year that James
Joyce completed Ulysses perhaps the
greatest work of fiction the world has
ever seen we call this period the Irish
revival or Irish Renaissance the period
when Ireland attained its identity as a
nation and as a culture this
extraordinary moment in Irish history
will be the focus of this course to
fully understand how the Irish revival
could happen we will plunge back into
the past and trace the roots of the
evolution of Ireland over the centuries
but first let me give you just a
sampling of the incredible cultural
dynamism the passion and the creative
tensions that characterized Ireland in
the early decades of the 20th century
imagine yourself in 1907 and we're in
the seats of the Abbey Theatre in Dublin
the Abbey is only a few years old and
it's the new Irish National Theatre it's
the place where the Irish can come to
see themselves reflected on the stage to
see their culture and their values so
long repressed and restrained by their
English rulers put before them with
nobility and grace tonight a new play is
being performed
the Playboy of the Western world by JMC
but something is wrong
halfway through the play the audience is
growing restless and agitated and then
in the third act they explode into
outrage and riot shouting down the
actors throwing debris on the stage and
almost causing the whole performance to
stop what is it in this apparently
rollicking comedy that is so outraged
this Irish audience why are they so
upset at how they've seen themselves
presented on the stage consider another
scene it is a June morning of 1904 on
the shore of Dublin Bay and three young
men are sitting in an abandoned tower
built by the British in the early 1800s
to guard the Irish coast from a feared
invasion by Napoleon one is a sensitive
Irish poet one is a medical student and
the third is a visitor from England
collecting folklore about the Irish
people and the English visitor turns to
the young Irish poet and says after all
I should think you are able to free
yourself you are your own master it
seems to me the Irish poet responds
grimly I am the servant of two masters
an English and an Italian what do you
mean asked the Englishman and the poet
responds the Imperial British state and
the Holy Roman Catholic and Apostolic
Church why would this young Irish poet
declare himself a servant of two masters
1 the British state the other the Roman
Catholic Church that story comes from
James Joyce's 1922 epic Ulysses one of
the most profound meditations on what it
means to be Irish in the 20th century
here the young poet suggests that to be
Irish means to be in struggle with the
masters of state and church and one more
scene it's the very early morning of
December 6 1921
in Downing Street London where the
leaders of the Irish rebellion have been
negotiating a treaty with the Prime
Minister of Great Britain all in the
wake of a three-year war of independence
that came in the aftermath of World War
one after weeks of negotiations at last
they are signing the peace agreement and
the chief negotiator for the irish
michael collins the very man who led
such a brilliant campaign of guerrilla
warfare against the british looks at the
sign treaty and exclaims i have signed
my own death warrant within months of
the treaties ratification ireland will
plunge into a brutal civil war that will
last nearly a year how could this happen
after nearly seven centuries of struggle
for independence when that independence
is finally achieved how could either
then devolve into a struggle in which
brother kills brother this is just a
suggestion of the enormous complexity
that constitutes the cultural and
political reality of Ireland in the 20th
century these three scenes show how
remarkable this period is how food 'fl
how tragic and how inspiring the stories
behind these scenes and the many more
like them make up what we can call the
Irish identity our central concern in
this course over the series of these
lectures we will start to see how Irish
identity develops through many twists
and turns over the centuries Irish
identity is always multiple always
layered with invasions and migrations in
one wave after another it is an identity
of astonishing resilience marked by
tremendous suffering and great
experiences of joy it is defined by a
love of nature and a powerful
relationship with God and it is best
comprehended by closely examining both
Irish history and the expressions of
Irish history and the great literature
art and crafts work of the Irish people
to begin to understand how the Irish
came to be we're going to go back in
time many thousands of years for Ireland
begins not in history but in the misty
legends and ancient ruins of the
prehistoric in the remnants of people
about whom we know only tales and songs
yet these vague beginnings are precisely
the roots out of which blossomed the
great writers of the late nineteenth and
early twentieth century if as James
Joyce famously wrote we are what we were
then the Irish Renaissance of 1900 can
only be understood by going far back
into the origins of the Irish themselves
let's start by addressing this
fundamental question who were the first
the original Irish well in a way there
is no such thing we know little of the
people who were indigenous to Ireland in
prehistoric times farming communities
existed in Ireland as much as 5,000
years ago during the Stone Age and the
Irish landscape is still marked by the
presence of these people particularly in
their enormous burial sites perhaps the
greatest example of such a site is the
huge portal tomb at Poole 'no broom in
the Far West of Ireland which dates to
perhaps the fourth millennium BC Pula
Brune is located in the heart of the
burren an enormous expanse of limestone
rock that resembles a lunar landscape
that rock is scored by multiple fissures
and cracks and the unique environment
allows flora from the Mediterranean from
the Arctic and Alpine growth all to
flourish they're brilliantly colored
delicate flowers can be seen creeping
through the grey and Silverstone the
tomb itself stands over six feet high
and consists of two standing stones
about a foot thick four feet long and
six feet high that support the enormous
capstone
which is the same dimensions but a full
12 feet long beneath the portal lies a
burial tomb or cairn within which the
remains of human beings were buried how
the tomb was constructed is a mystery
how what ancient man have heaves such a
massive stone into place its angle and
position suggest that it is already
entered up towards the cosmos that the
souls of the Dead buried within the
chamber are meant to be projected out
into the stars releasing the souls from
the earth and returning them to the
heavens similar tombs temples and burial
chambers exist all throughout Ireland
and none is more spectacular than the
great monument at Newgrange this site
was built around 3100 BC centuries
before the egyptian pyramids located in
the Boyne River Valley about 30 miles
northwest of modern-day Dublin Newgrange
was constructed by ancient farming
communities that thrived in the rich
Valley land the site is an enormous
megalithic burial tomb a raised mound of
Earth nearly 40 feet high and 250 feet
long that extends over a full acre it
contains a burial chamber that runs for
nearly 60 feet where ancient human
remains have been found but it is much
more than a tomb
Newgrange was surely a ceremonial center
a place of worship of communal gathering
of astrological significance and of
cultic and ritual events the first
archaeologists to fully excavate
Newgrange called it the Cathedral of the
Neolithic religion the outside is
surrounded by nearly 100 massive curb
stones that are richly decorated with a
variety of abstract art Chevron's
spirals serpentine forms and more
scholars have long debated the
significance of these art forms and the
culture
beliefs that they express they clearly
reveal to us a culture that valued
abstract art and the connections between
human art and the cosmos but the true
glory of Newgrange is the enormous
burial chamber as it extends back into
the mound multiple repositories line the
sides here it's likely that the bones of
the dead princes and kings were
deposited for a site such as this would
have been used for only royal burials
the chamber is essentially a long narrow
tunnel issuing in a larger chamber that
may have been reserved for the most
elite rulers both burnt and unburned
human remains have been found in this
chamber above the entrance door there is
a small stone box with a carefully
carved opening in the middle about the
size of a large shoebox on the 22nd day
of December at the dawn after the
longest darkest night of the year the
Rising Sun would shine through that
small opening and slowly illuminate the
entire chamber with dazzling light
scholars speculate that the Newgrange
builders were sun worshippers and they
carefully constructed their ritual
center so that at the moment of greatest
darkness they could experience the
return of light the dark death of winter
would give way to the promise of
continued Sun of spring and growth and
rebirth and the ongoing life of the
creation the cult of the Dead as one
scholar describes Newgrange believed
that this return of the Sun would return
the bones of the ancestors to life and
death would be defeated for another year
even today standing in that ancient
chamber is a powerful experience and
still five thousand years after it was
built the chamber at Newgrange aligns
with the Sun at the dawn after the
winter solstice and fills with the light
of
creation whoever these ancient people
were they accomplished astonishing feats
of engineering astronomy and art their
memory lives on in the Irish landscape
another site of great importance is the
Hill of Tara also located in that
fertile Boyne Valley in the eastern part
of Ireland Tara is the legendary site of
the Irish high kings going back to the
Celtic period in the Iron Age a thousand
years before the coming of st. Patrick
the hill rises high above the
surrounding countryside and it commands
a view on the rare clear day of as many
as half the counties of Ireland these
eminences and high places are always
associated with mystical power and
divine authority in the Irish landscape
other examples include Mount Brandon on
the Dingle Peninsula associated with
Saint Brendan the navigator and CRO
Patrick in County Mayo each of which had
earlier pre-christian Celtic and
mythical associations as well the
eleventh century work the book of
invasions a pseudo historical chronicle
of the waves of invaders to Ireland from
the creation of the world all the way to
the early Middle Ages describes Terra as
the seat of the High King or re
archaeological excavations have revealed
a number of structures and monuments
that confirm Terra's royal and symbolic
significance a large enclosure stood
atop the hill where ceremonies and
rituals would have taken place a long
avenue leads all the way up to the
summit this is called the
banqueting-hall
but it most likely was a processional
road for ritual ceremony and entrance to
the hill the ancient roads in Ireland
all led to Tara and one can imagine the
ancient peoples processing as for
pilgrimage to the hill to worship and
show respect for the king at
top of the hill is the leaf fall or the
stone of destiny
according to legend when the true King
touched the leaf all the stone would
scream out in recognition of the Kings
hand other earthworks and burial
chambers suggest solar alignment similar
to those at Newgrange though Terra seems
to be more aligned with the vernal and
autumnal equinox --is whereas Newgrange
is aligned to the winter solstice
Newgrange is the older site though
certainly some sort of ceremony or
ritual would have been occurring at
Terra around the same time Terra however
is more closely associated with the
Celtic peoples the first documented
historical population of Ireland for we
can say that true Irish history and
Irish identity begins with the Celts now
who were the Celts they were originally
a northern European people who
flourished throughout Europe from about
the 7th century BC up to about the 1st
century BC when the expansion of the
Roman Empire and the migrations of the
Germanic and Slavic peoples constricted
the Celts to the western islands the
Celts entered Ireland along with Wales
and Scotland perhaps as early as 500 BC
and began what we now refer to as Irish
civilization and what I've been
referring to as Irish myth and legend
emerges from the culture of these people
an Irish or Celtic mythology is a
fascinating rich provocative body of
belief and lore that will recur
throughout every period of Irish history
and it will be especially potent to the
writers of the Irish revival whom we
will study now though the Celts might
have a somewhat savage reputation and
popular thought in fact Celtic culture
was rich and diverse and in many ways
quite advanced
the Celts had great skill in iron man
they're iron longswords falcata or
curved swords battle axes javelins
spears armor and shields made them truly
formidable in battle and the Celts were
also quite advanced in agriculture
hunting warfare and road building in
fact the famous Roman roads were often
just expanded versions overlaid upon the
original Celtic road system the Celts
were also supremely gifted artists and
craftsmen particularly in jewelry
metalwork and weaponry torx bracelets
cauldrons and necklaces were carefully
and exquisitely wrought their social
structure was one of tribes and kings
governed by a system of laws and
interpreted judgments called Breton law
and their religion was a kind of Earth
and Sun worship known generally as
Druidism and the druid was a combination
of priests astrologer lawgiver and poet
essentially a figure of knowledge and
wisdom there's evidence that there were
female druids and that schools much like
early universities existed for the
training and education of the druids the
Celtic religion was a complex polytheism
they had over 400 named gods and
goddesses the greatest of their gods was
the Dada
both the destroyer and the creator his
club would kill if struck from one end
and bring back to life if struck with
the other like the Hindu god Shiva the
Dada was a triple God who could
simultaneously create preserve and
destroy and this tripartite structure of
belief seems to have been deeply
ingrained in Celtic spiritualism they
viewed the human being as consisting of
body soul and spirit they saw the world
as consisting of three elements of earth
sea and air and they thought the world
of nature consisted of the animal the
vegetable and the mineral
and many have speculated that this is
one reason why the Celts in Ireland
embraced Christianity so readily its
Trinitarian theology seemed an obvious
and natural way to make sense of the
divine and as the Irish historian Peter
Ellis has pointed out it was a Celtic
theologian hilary of poitiers in the mid
4th century ad who gave the fullest
definition of the Christian Trinity in
his work day Trinity a the Celts traced
their own origins to the Great Mother
Goddess Dan new meaning the divine
waters from heaven the great goddess of
fertility and life she's associated with
creation with maternity and with
regeneration in the hills surrounding
Killarney and county kerry in the far
southwest of Ireland two mountains rise
up that are called the paps of Anu the
breasts of the mother goddess from whom
fertility and life
flow like the other high places in
Ireland these have long been the site of
ritual worship and ceremony
Danny's children were the two aahed a
Donnan which means the children of Dan
knew they constitute the bountiful array
of gods goddesses and heroes who
eventually would form the major figures
in Irish mythology other key figures in
the Celtic Pantheon included Luke god of
light and of crafts he was the harvest
God and was celebrated at the end of
summer in the festival of Lughnasa and
Brigid was their goddess of fertility
and healing who in the Christian
dispensation became Saint Brigid
patroness of the home the Celts believed
in the afterlife seeing it as in many
ways a continuation of this life and of
course they were great warriors a
martial culture renowned even by the
Romans for their bravery and fierceness
so it was
to this culture that the first Christian
missionaries came in the early 400s the
most famous of these of course was st.
Patrick
by any measure Patrick was a truly
remarkable man a Briton and a Roman
citizen born into a prosperous family he
was kidnapped by Celtic slavers when he
was 16 years old and he spent the next
six years as a slave in Ireland there he
experienced a profound religious
conversion and remarkably he escaped
from Ireland he became a priest than a
bishop and studied in Europe where he
developed the conviction that he must
return to Ireland and bring the truth of
Christianity to the very people who had
made him a slave in 432 Patrick returns
to Ireland and for the next three
decades he traversed virtually the
entire country establishing churches
appointing priests and bishops spreading
the word about the Christian God and
ministering to the Irish people the
legend of his exploits are many most
famous is his explanation to the Irish
of the Christian Trinity using the
three-leaf Shamrock to communicate the
mystery of three persons in a single God
he convinced the Celts of the power of
his new divinity when he lit the fire on
the hill of slain which extinguished the
sacred fire on the nearby Hill of Tara
that had been lit by the Celtic King of
course there's the story of how he
charmed all the snakes out of Ireland
symbolically banishing the devil from
the island in point of fact there hadn't
been snakes in Ireland since the last
ice age and his presence still marks the
Irish landscape today in holy Wells
mountains and pilgrim trails and
virtually every part of the island crow
Patrick in the northwest is renowned as
Patrick's holy mountain where he is said
to have fasted and prayed for 40 days to
this day tens of thousands of pilgrims
walk up it's well-worn path to the peak
to pray in st. Patrick's Cathedral in
Dublin a grave slab was uncovered that
revealed an ancient holy well that's
associated with Patrick's baptisms from
the fifth century and beyond legend and
tall tale
Patrick was clearly an incredibly
charismatic figure and an inspiring
leader it is remarkable that he achieved
a virtually bloodless conversion and
that in essentially a single generation
a pagan country became a Christian one
during this same period Rome was sacked
by the Visigoths and then by the Vandals
and the so-called Dark Ages began in
Europe Roman order was eroded urban
centers declined libraries were
destroyed and the wealth and leisure on
which learned civilization depends
vanished before warfare and plunder if
this destruction had been complete we
would have lost virtually all of Greek
and Roman poetry history science oratory
philosophy in short the whole of
classical civilization upon which the
European Renaissance itself was based
but in Ireland this small island at the
extreme western edge of Europe where the
Romans never came and of which the
barbarians had hardly even heard the
treasures of classical culture were
preserved the remarkable institution
that made this preservation possible was
Irish monasticism Patrick's effort was
largely one of conversion and baptism
but in the century that followed his
ministry a series of saints founded
monasteries that would thrive for the
next thousand years the Irish monastic
system was remarkably well suited to
preserve the classical culture of Europe
the Irish monks were community makers
they established schools and spread
literacy and learning throughout Ireland
their monastic settlements were vibrant
and socially connected communities at
clonmacnoise in County Offaly
glendalough in County Wicklow
monasteries and Kells in County Mead the
monasteries were like towns with lodging
crafts farming and trade flourishing and
some of their settlements were
exceptionally remote such as skellig
michael built on a granite outcropping 8
miles off the western coast of ireland
literally the last land of Europe before
the vastness of the Atlantic here monks
for centuries sought God in the most
isolated remote location one could
imagine a version of the early church
fathers who journeyed into the isolation
of the desert to find God and of course
they also contained schools libraries
and script toria in the scriptorium the
monks performed perhaps their most
important labor slowly carefully
artistically they copied page by page
the great books of Greek and Roman
culture many brought to Ireland by monks
fleeing the ravages of mainland Europe
it could take escribe months or even
years to copy out certain books and a
massive undertaking such as the Bible
would be daunting indeed but this was
the monastic life in early Christian
Ireland regular prayer and worship in
the community church labor in the garden
plots for food and copying out the great
books of the Ancients in their
communities with the bell in the
characteristic Irish high tower tolling
the hours the monks labored to preserve
the crucial knowledge of humankind in
the centuries that followed they would
travel back to mainland Europe returning
with these texts restoring classical
culture to the ravaged land this is what
the historian
as Cahill describes as how the Irish
saved civilization the Irish monks not
only transcribed the Greek and Latin of
the Classical Age they also preserve the
language and oral traditions of their
own culture of the Irish they knew the
Irish language anew it's great stories
legends songs and poems they wrote these
works down preserving the oldest living
vernacular in all of Europe the great
Irish epic the toy in beaucoup Li or the
brown bowl of [ __ ] they wrote out in
all its pagan glory here the great
warrior coholan
battled to preserve Ulster from the
invading tribes of may the queen of
Connacht as she tried to wrest the great
bull from the Ulsterman in this epoch
given written form around the 6th
century AD we see a glimpse into the
violent heroic glorious world of the
Iron Age Celtic people the monks also
wrote down the great mythological tales
of the early Irish the sagas of
invasions of such legendary races as the
furballs the my lesions and farther back
the children of Dan knew the to aahed a
Donnan according to legend the two aahed
a Donnan were eventually defeated by the
next invaders the gales and they
withdrew from the surface world to dwell
into hillsides and the underground forts
and become the fairies so famous in
Irish folklore the monks put into
written form for the first time the
great tales of Finn McCool and his
warriors of the Fionna and of the great
kings at Tara and their followers Dermot
and granya Oshin in the land of the
young Deirdre of the sorrows and many
other marvellous moving legends are
contained in the monastic manuscripts
and these are the myths and tales that
would so fascinate the Irish imagination
in the 1890s when WB Yeats and his
colleagues in the Irish revival
turn to the iris past to restore the
Irish identity Yeats wrote in 1898 that
his poetry depended on the passions and
beliefs of ancient times and the
fountain of Gaelic legends that was just
being opened and the Irish monks
preserved them all we see in the
marginal poems and personal writings of
these monks essential aspects of what we
will come to see as the Irish identity a
love of nature an endless search for God
a need for solitude along with a
powerful desire for community and
especially a dedication to learning and
knowledge in the famous phrase of one of
the great poems from this period pange
or bond the monks life purpose consists
in turning darkness into light we
certainly see the same impulse driving
the great writers of the Irish revival
period Yeats will claim that he and his
fellow revivalist seek quote that
eternal and ancient Ireland which has
lived from old times in tender and
heroic tales and in the unwary love of
many thousand men and women who have
been poor in all other things this time
of the Irish monasteries remains an
idyllic and triumphant age in Irish
history the monks living in peace and
harmony preserving classical
civilization and the Irish past yet
while this triumphant and heroic
restoration of culture to mainland
Europe was occurring a new threat was
appearing in Ireland itself as yet
another invading culture appear these of
course were the Northmen the terrifying
Vikings whose arrival on the island
would add a new dimension to the
ever-evolving Irish identity
you